we got the story from the daily mail
exclusive
joe biden could become embroiled in the
fbi's probe into hunter's finances
experts say i love that experts say
emails reveal they shared bank accounts
paid each other's bills and the
president may have even funded his son's
2018 drug and prostitution binge
we're gonna be a little careful on this
one because we try to be a
family-friendly show but uh when it
comes to the president and his son it's
anything but family-friendly from joe
biden touching children and sniffing
them inappropriately to his son doing
crack i'm sorry we can only cover up so
much in an attempt to protect your
children's ears the daily mail says
president joe biden could become
embroiled in an fbi investigation let me
just stop and say yeah right as if
they're going to do anything
emails recovered by dailymail.com from
hunter's abandoned laptop his uh between
his business him and uh between hunter
and eric schwerin his business partner
at roosevelt seneca show schwerin was
working on joe's taxes discussing the
father and son paying each other's
household bills and even fielding
requests for a book deal for them by the
vice for the then vice president yes it
is unclear why schwerin
had the intimate role in the vice
president's affairs rather than
government officials in the oval in the
office of the vice president hunter's
claim that he and his father shared a
bank account also raises serious
questions whether funds from the alleged
joint account were used for hunter's may
2018 week-long vendor well look if you
have a bank account it's got a dollar in
it and then someone puts a dollar in it
the money is mixed up now and then if
you take a dollar out yeah sorry we
don't play that game this is how like
you know when when the feds go after
money laundering you can't just be like
it's one bank account but all of our
money is different they're gonna be like
nah you're mixing it all together
they say last december hunter admitted
in a public statement that he was under
federal investigation over his tax
affairs all right let's let's slow down
for a second so now we're learning
joe biden sharing a bank out with his
son
hunter biden on the board of barisma
getting paid was 83 thousand dollars per
month yeah
bursma being investigated or i should
say micholas lachewski the founder of it
being investigated by the prosecutor
victor shulkin joe biden goes to ukraine
and says if you don't fire the
prosecutor you don't get there was it a
billion dollars yeah it was huge and so
they say okay fine they fire the
prosecutor official narrative from the
u.s establishment mainstream medias oh
they fired him because he wasn't
investigating this guy
so
hunter biden who has no business being
on the board of this company a company
that's under investigation getting paid
83 grand sharing a bank account with his
dad his dad then goes in
fires a prosecutor who is investigating
the company we know this from matt
tybee's reporting
sounds like joe biden was protecting his
own assets by going to ukraine
getting this guy fired
it wasn't about corruption it was it
wasn't about anything other than his own
corruption so what what what do we do
with information like that
i'm shrugging through those do a tv show
and talk about it do it unfortunately
you already have the tv show so let's
talk about it we can all shake our fists
in the air and then tomorrow wake up
because nothing changes no this dude's a
scumbag and i think this is going to be
big news you can they hid the they tried
to hide the laptop scandal
with the post story yeah you brought up
a very important point here ian the the
fact that there was so much censorship
especially around the hunter biden email
stories because this i mean the daily
mail says that they got the story from
the emails so the fact that there was so
much suppression shows that they
actually do care about what the public
thinks about them they actually do need
the public to acquiesce and there's a
large number of voters that said that if
they knew about these emails they would
they would have voted differently so so
this of course has a lot of implications
i mean we know he lied about the uh on
the atf form when it comes to buying
firearms he lied about a lot of other
things as well that he should have been
you know kept you know be held
responsible for liable for i mean the
guy is on video committing acts there's
photos of him committing acts that we
can't even mention here on youtube let
me let me let me read this portion of
the story because y'all's jaws are gonna
hit the floor no hunter and schwarin
privately discussed the potential to
ingratiate themselves with quote ceos of
the major banks if they helped arrange
the request this is to senator robert
menendez uh who requested vp biden host
the u.s spain's council 2010 annual
meeting as official naval observatory
residents in dc they contacted schwerin
rather than joe's white house office
interestingly we then see this
hunter complained that half of his
salary went to paying his father's bills
while he was vp casting doubt on joe's
previous claim that he's never benefited
from his son's business dealings in a
2019 text to his daughter naomi he wrote
i hope you all can do what i did and pay
for everything for this entire family
for 30 years it's really hard but don't
worry unlike pop i won't make you give
me half your salary so that's previously
uncovered information
now we have joe biden sharing a bank
account with his son this is let me
explain something to you
i have i have an accountant and i'm like
hey what can i do to help you know help
my family out and he goes nothing oh
nothing
you cannot do anything special for
family for the most part for the most
part there's certain things like friends
and family you know with investment
stuff but if you want to give someone
money it's taxed
it's either a gift up to a certain limit
right now i believe the limit is 15 000
and after that you gotta pay taxes on it
if they're splitting bank accounts and
they're as wealthy as you know we know
they're wealthy then
this is what is his tax avoidance how
much money went into this bank account i
don't know for sure we don't we i i
don't know for sure and i think the
issue is
as soon as they mix their finances
questions have to be raised about any
and all of their finances all of them
yeah i was going to say i heard a really
familiar voy a really familiar name in
the story and that was bob menendez do
you guys remember bob menendez and what
he got in trouble for
something about the dominican republic
and some kind of young women young
ladies yes we'll put it that way so as
far as i'm concerned i don't see
anything bad ever happening to the
bidens based on what happened to bob
menendez aka nothing i don't think
anything's gonna happen how do you look
it's kind of it's kind of funny when you
know under trump they were like trump
won't be investigated because bill barr
is as lackey and it's never gonna happen
and i'm sitting here like in merrick
garland what's he gonna do you think
merrick garland's gonna go after joe
biden and be like lock him up he's going
to be like hey joe they're talking about
you can i have some money
there you go yep
i think it's also hilarious that this is
the same president lecturing parents
about how they should raise their
children
i mean i mean
let's be serious here i mean
if if you're hunter biden's father you
can't be telling other people how to
raise your children you can't be telling
people to you know given them specific
because he came out and said you know if
you're if you're not following the
science if you're not taking these
procedures you're not raising your
children right and um again there's a
lot to say about that but there's just
so much corruption so much dirtiness i
mean we have the flights to china we
have the business dealings with ukraine
we have so many companies just
intertwined and and yesterday on the
show i specifically said sorry i'm
having like headphones problems and i
keep hearing myself back so i keep
getting
distracted it's just weird hearing your
own voice but but there's so many
instances and as i said yesterday
you know this country has been sold for
pennies on the dollar and the way you
buy influence the way that you buy off
politicians the way that our system
works is incredibly easy for a third
party to come in and to manipulate this
for their own benefit in so many
different ways having dirt having videos
of biden doing unspeakable things with
women with relatives with family members
i mean that's top-notch top-level
extortion level uh material that could
be leveraged that we knew that we know
many foreign countries had before now
this is what we know what don't we know
about what wasn't in the emails that we
still don't know about that many that
maybe foreign countries have that could
be using to exploit the current
president of the united states you know
how i feel about this story i feel like
you know we get this bombshell
revelation oh joe biden sharing banks
like they're funding each other and joe
biden you know potentially paying for
hookers and stuff i feel like i just bar
burst into the room and i'm like
everybody listen
joe biden's are corrupt and everyone's
like oh [ __ ] we know
but we have the story and they're like
yeah whatever
what do you do
are we going to see a a red wave in 2022
maybe an impeachment the dude needs to
be impeached please yeah then we're
going to have you know president kamala
and her child actors that she hires yeah
laughing to the camera as she like does
weird strange bizarre videos promoting
space and looking at the craters of the
moon for some reason it's it's
reassuring you know you know with all
the economic calamities with so much
problems that that the white house is
spending money on child actors to convey
people about looking at the moon uh i
mean are you freaking kidding me they're
so out of touch with reality they hope
no one's paying attention they want you
to feel like hey there's so much
corruption it's just okay it's the new
norm it's not it's not okay and i think
there's a reason what ian brought up
here that censorship happened of these
emails the censorship was crucial i
think it would have made a big impact in
the elections and i think it's going to
make an impact later down the line in
this political spectrum when people look
at the president look at the clear
corruption look at the clear dereliction
of duty look at the cleared mess left by
him and being like how could have we not
seen this happening well because of big
tech social online censorship
i would like to make two points
i would like to make two points about
that
guys in chat are going that's about my
not being loud enough so
right
i would like to point out i would like
to say that jean baudrillard is going to
be spinning in his grave over that stunt
that kamala pulled
absolutely unbelievable because every
ounce of that is fake
the whole thing is a pre-fabricated
commercial
where you're supposed to bring people in
so that they can kamala has a chance to
go out and impress them so to set up to
begin with but it's not even a real
setup
it's a it's supposed to be a setup of a
spontaneous moment but it's not even a
real setup of a spontaneous moment it's
a fake
setup of a spontaneous moment it's two
levels of fake it's a fake of a fake
it's a copy of a copy so they have
actors who are paid to act like they're
real people so that kamala can come in
and act like a spontaneous moment that's
not set up and prefabricated ahead of
time that they auditioned for yes so you
had to audition
for a spontaneous moment
what a creepy fake reality who's the
last genuine president i guess trump was
not no he wasn't he wasn't genuine
either the way he said uh now i'm
getting that weird tinny sound of my
headphones the way he said uh
gee lane he hopes wishes are well i i
don't know i think trump was very
straightforward and he just bluntly said
that and many other things maybe trump
before that jimmy carter because reagan
was full of it i try to watch old
interviews with reagan and he's just
like smiling and like oh they're gonna
use the knife it's all theater it's all
a show that's why they're literally
building a stage for joe biden to not be
in the white house in that's that's as
it's it's played on like like a theater
yeah everything we're seeing is just
horse and pony it's all a showcase it's
meant to fool you into this larger kind
of illusion that they actually have
power over you when they when they
desperately need to have that conviction
well we have more news ladies and
gentlemen
joe biden's aggregate approval rating is
just getting massively worse breaking a
new record high disapproval and a new
record low approval wow this is just
it's getting bad disapproval is at 52.3
his approval is down to 43. and look at
this major spike
regular people are starting to wake up
to what's going on joe biden is bad he
is corrupt his leadership is failing
this country we've got a southern border
crisis an economic crisis a jobs crisis
a mass resignation crisis an inflation
crisis stagflation shrink flation just
any kind of inflation just maybe you got
it yeah you got all of them
enough to go around for everybody it
looks like that inflection points were
right about when he
came out with this mandate nonsense it's
true yeah right around the time he
announced the man when the mandate
started becoming big there was a major
swap and by the way those aren't actual
mandates osha has not approved these
things yet right
it was his announcement of a rule to be
and osha has not implemented any rules
and there's no executive order yet we're
seeing all these businesses just go
along with it
this is what i think
a lot of people
anti-elected trump
as we mentioned over and over again in
the show that there was at articles just
stay alive joe biden right and this is
what you get when you don't have a
legitimate
like administration
and what i mean by that is an
administration that is actually going to
do the job that is actually having the
meetings joe biden is probably asleep
with a with a burlap blanket on his on
his laps in the sun snoring all day
while kamala is just like what do i
gotta do to make it seem like i'm
working give me some child actress or
something and i'll just pretend and then
i'm done right that's that's where we're
at yeah you are here yep so biden was
unelected and we're seeing the result of
choosing people based on like color
their skin and their gender and sexual
orientation we're seeing pete buda judge
being totally incompetent kamala harris
just cackling her way through being a
terrible vice president it's tackling
her way through the vice president
it's so bad but this is what happens
when you hire people based on you know
checking a demographic box they're
totally incompetent and everyone's
shocked by this it's also what kind of
what happens when you
treat the political
realm like a reality tv show they just
put they want monkey dance monkey dance
and then they get entertainers and
stupid people in chart doing the dance
and the people that are willing to do
the dance do the dance and the people
everyone else builds spaceships
so who's building a spaceship is it on i
just wanted
mr musk can i take a chance to just
drive something home yes
we are living in a post-modern era i
keep screaming about this on twitter and
this is how i kind of built my following
we are now living in post-modernism is
that why does it make sense that is why
well it's not coherent it doesn't need
to make sense this is post-modernism um
i always say that trump is our first
post-modern president he was the first
president of the fully post-modern age
the age of narrative where truth doesn't
matter
so you can see that in the entire media
circus around trump or even the fact
checks aren't real right right you're
they're not the fact checks are not to
check if the facts are real they're to
check if they're the appropriate facts
that they approve of right are these
approved facts are these the facts that
are helpful to us right
so that's what goes on there and then
as we as we've moved through the biden
presidency
everything about it is fake they built a
fake room so that he could pretend to be
in the white house right
[Laughter]
we had we had kamala bring child actors
on she could pretend to be surprised to
have an authentic moment right and to be
genuine allegedly yeah so we had a fake
genuine moment yeah that's great yeah
we're having we're going to stage a
genuine moment for them
so that the people can have a genuine
moment to look at while they're watching
president biden get vaccined in the
white house
in the fake room in the white house this
is this is all simulation it's it's
completely
it's it's an era of complete and utter
inauthenticity
so you've got
there is nothing about it which touches
reality at any point it's entirely
staged it doesn't refer to anything
nothing about it is
rooted in the real world experience of
anybody that's why you have actors who
audition for it it's not just they
brought actors in and said have a good
time or brought actors in and said hear
your line they brought actors in and
said you have to audition
for the genuineness and surprise
how do you audition for a surprise
how do you audition to be surprised what
does that even mean well actors probably
do it all the time in movies or whatever
yeah i i think a better word than
simulation is simulacrum yes the the the
the uh simulation implies there's a
functioning you know system and we're
trying like is it real no it's a
caricature and and i i i want to make
sure i got the definition right an
insubstantial replication
it is very obvious
you know uh it's like
it's like a caricature we're looking at
a caricature of an administration mm-hmm
yeah i would agree with that
i think james o'keefe really
characterized this well where he
compared what's happening now to 1984
when they're asking you to reject the
evidence of your eyes and ears so i
think we're at that particular phase
right now where literally we have
evidence we have photos we have
documentation we have witnesses we have
whistleblowers coming forward screaming
saying hey there's some awful things
happening in this world there's some
really bad people doing horrible things
and then the mainstream media is like
it's weather there's bad weather and and
regurgitating all this nonsense and lies
that is absolutely nonsensical and
anyone paying attention to to anything
that's happening it's just an insult to
their intelligence i got a feeling that
because it seems like since the internet
i started noticing them lying and
creating a mass narrative that's not
real but before the internet i never
realized it but i think they were just
doing it then anyway they're just using
abc news to push it
and now at least it's obvious that
there's no weapons of mass destruction
in iraq yeah and it's not just child
actors that they're hiring they're
they're they're hiring social media uh
influencers they're they're hiring
doctors they're hiding uh they're hiring
other doctor the other uh actors
they're hiring everyone to kind of prop
them up as this kind of legitimate force
and then when we really look at it a lot
of it is phony a lot of it is based on
lies a lot of it is based on here we'll
give you this money just say these lines
and sadly some people do that you guys
know the story uh we've talked about a
lot kindergarten's clown you know he
comes out and he's like there's a fire
in the back and then everyone starts
laughing and he's like no seriously
there's a fire and they laugh even
harder and he says i think that's how
the world will end you know whatever it
kind of feels like it's the other way
around you know there's there's a small
group of us and we're sitting in the
audience and on tv is all of these
people
that are all pretending like there's no
fire and we're the ones yelling back
like there is a fire and they're like no
and they just they're just they're
putting on a show they're performing it
kind of feels like we we now exist with
a government
of people who are basically like
uh what time is it um what do i have to
do to pretend to do the job so that i
can get paid and go home
kamala harris comes out some child
actors biden builds a fake set you know
what you know what you why i don't
understand the fake set but i can say
biden likes to go home a lot it sure
does no but none of these people want to
be working
well you hire people who didn't who
weren't right for the job this is what
you get to be fair i sympathize with i
understand people don't want to be at
work most the time i can't really relate
because i love my job but i will say
that this very much to me looks like a
case of bread and circuses and when
you're seeing it in your politics i
think that's
unsettling that's a serious issue
so can i can i throw something out yeah
i'd like to toss something out i think
i think what we're seeing is what i like
to call the strawberry slurpee of a
presidency
okay so here's here's what i mean
suppose we go back in time and we find
some original natural organic
strawberries we picked them we eat them
they taste pretty good fast forward to
the 1960s and all of a sudden we can we
can farm strawberries and we only take
the biggest reddest juiciest
strawberries for consumption we'll call
that a productive coffee well then
someone comes along and says hey we're
in those big juicy strawberries well we
can make a strawberry candy out of it
okay well then we go a little further
and someone else says yeah we can make a
strawberry candy but we're gonna add
some sugar
okay then someone else comes along and
says yeah we'll make a strawberry candy
but we'll use corn syrup instead of
sugar then someone else says we'll make
a soft drink of the candy and then
somebody else comes along and says we
are going to make a strawberry slurry
slurpee that is flavored like the soda
that is flavored like the candy that is
flavored like the straw and all of a
sudden you're you're so far away from
the original thing that they're not even
comparable the flavor of the strawberry
slurpee is nothing like the flavor of
the organic of the organic thing what we
have right now for a presidency
is nothing like what it's supposed to be
it's entirely entirely what they think
people expect a presidency to look like
that's why they have to build a set so
they can get the perfect angle so that
they can create the image of what they
think people expect a presidency to be
at the cost of what an actual presidency
might actually be if one was really
occurring i i do got some some bad news
to add to that i think raspberry might
be a better example because you guys
know where they get the flavoring for a
raspberry artificial flavor beavers yeah
yeah it's beaver ancient yeah
yeah
it's the beaver angle blend i think it
is beaver butt
you think you're eating this delicious
it's it's strawberry they say you're
eating a strawberry you take a bite and
you're like hmm
yeah it's kind of like strawberry
storium and they're like yellowish
real it's actually it's actually just
from beaver butt that's right that's
biden's presidency yeah so you're eating
some artificial gmo monsanto gene
spliced strawberry shake that doesn't
taste anything like it was supposed to
and it can't but
this is normal since this is what they
gave you since you're a small child even
worse about that is the the the flavor
is not the point it's what you the
nutrition you get from a strawberry you
eat so now we got
we've got
mutilated dis flavor
you're not even getting any of the
nutrition that you need from the valid
strawberry presidency it's not just
biden it's everything
yeah the whole government it's the whole
government it's congress it's the senate
i think they built that room for like
implementing a special teleprompter
that's really big that they can't fit in
the white house or just some kind of new
medical advice that like wakes him up
and zaps him
there has to be some there has to be
some reason sometimes
he's got a gigantic series of cables in
his back that go down into a massive
power system it's a giant reactor to
keep him alive he's robo biden that
would make more you remember when i'd
make more sense franklin and rose
franklin dylan roosevelt started uh he
got paralyzed i think was it polio that
took his legs his walk wasn't he always
no not in the beginning of his
presidency and they hit it for like i
don't know how long two years or
something they hit it yeah so what i
imagine with biden i mean the guy is
decrepit if that's the right word he's
like almost falling over
that's the right word yeah
like if you listened to ten years ago
are they hiding it
they've done it before yeah i i don't
know but i i want to go back to your
point about the nutrition thing because
i think it's it's just a perfect point
all of the stuff that should be going on
in congress
isn't
none of it's going on but if you go to
congress it sure looks like there's
stuff going you've got people in suits
walking around very important people
people are exchanging business cards
there's capitol hill police there's a
lot of people that are walking around
looking very very busy they're holding
votes on things nothing's going on it's
entirely fake
this is baudrillard's point and this is
why i say we're living in a postmodern
moment we are living in a time of
the image is what matters the substance
is almost utterly irrelevant if it's
even seen at all thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you